one second you're out cold
the next
you're on the operating table
in the middle of heart surgery
welcome to your most terrifying
nightmare
what happens when anesthesia doesn't
work
would you feel everything that was going
on with your body
and
why wouldn't you be able to tell your
surgeon you're awake
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you woke up during heart
surgery
for
170 years anesthesia has enabled
countless life-saving surgeries without
pain
before that your surgeon would give you
numbing agents like alcohol or opium
they
weren't as effective of course thanks
i needed that
there are four main types of anesthesia
regional and local anesthetics numb
parts of your body but you remain
conscious and aware the other types are
sedation and general anesthesia
these are used in operations with
different levels of invasiveness
from a routine colonoscopy to a
quadruple bypass
they render you completely unconscious
but sometimes
things go sideways
and now you're in the middle of a highly
invasive heart operation
about to wake up to your own horror
movie
at first your eyes wouldn't be fully
open but you'd hear all the noises
around you
doctors talking equipment beeping and
your thoughts getting louder in your
head
as you gain more consciousness the
bright lights above you would be
blinding
and you would become aware of the tube
in your mouth connected to a ventilator
naturally you'd be confused and a bit
dazed
you might think the surgery was over but
as you lower your eyes to your chest you
would see the doctor cleaning your skin
they are about to make the first
incision
you'd start to panic and try to sit up
but you wouldn't be able to lift a
finger
it would feel as if someone was holding
you down
what you'd be experiencing is anesthesia
awareness
that's when you wake up during surgery
and with your complex heart surgery
lasting three to six hours
get ready for an excruciating time
the doctors would cut straight down the
center of your chest wall and just as in
your worst fears
you'd feel everything
intense pain would tear through your
body you'd try to scream but you
wouldn't be able to maybe you could
twitch your leg but the doctors would
assume that this was a muscle
contraction and they'd hold it down
your heart rate wouldn't increase
because your heart isn't beating
a heart lung bypass machine is moving
the blood away from your heart
now they'd cut into your breast bone and
open up your rib cage
the pain would be so intense that
you'd momentarily dip back out of
consciousness
when you wake back up after only a few
seconds
you'd feel like you're suffocating
the ventilator is pumping your lungs
artificially so no matter how much
stress or anxiety you feel
your body isn't in control
this happened in one case of a woman who
woke up during abdominal surgery
her general anesthesia wore off but she
remained somewhat paralyzed this led to
her having an out of body experience
this would be the best case scenario for
you too
the sounds of the operating room would
drift away
the pain and fear too
for a moment you'd feel warm and safe
maybe you'd even feel the presence of
something divine
but all the pain could come spiraling
back
and after all that stress and trauma you
could experience a heart attack
now your life would be on the line
lucky for you the doctors would
stabilize you
your surgeon would successfully bypass
the blocked artery in your heart
finally this nightmare of a surgery
would be over
but the entire experience wouldn't be
something you could walk away from
you could develop post-traumatic stress
disorder or
anxiety maybe even a phobia of lying
down flat on a bed
many things would suddenly bring back
painful memories
thankfully anesthesia awareness only
affects about 1 in 19 000 individuals
and for most of those impacted it's not
painfully traumatic as you just
experienced in our hypothetical scenario
besides waking up could just be better
than the alternative
slipping into a deep coma
but
that's a story
for another
what if
you